I'm going to ask you a question and you
give me the dollar amount what it's
worth okay okay let's play this game
what is a 1952
Mickey Mantle tops PSA 10 rookie card
worth to you for me nothing but okay for
you that's the point but that's that's
the answer so the answer is what it's
worth to you okay what is a uh a Ferrari
LaFerrari 2014 worth to you yeah I'm not
a car guy okay perfect so what is a uh
uh two uh uh be in a movie uh a Scorsese
movie with Joe Pesci Pacino and De Niro
what is it worth to you would you pay to
be in that movie lifetime goal what
would you pay to be in that movie
whatever I got it that's a lot but but
look what happened to you whenever you'd
pan a Ferrari whatever you pay for
Ferrari you would want to be in a movie
with and you got a key role Pesci De
Niro and Pacino right okay so to
somebody or somebody massage I don't
want to be in a movie I just want to
watch it you guys do it I'll go and
watch it I'm not going to be okay what
is it worth to you to travel to Monaco
and have dinner at Le Louis with every
living president what does it work to
you it's interesting five hour then what
is a word to you what would you pay for
it I'm being serious what would you pay
would you pay a million bucks to go to
something like that I had it yeah if you
had it you would it would be worth going
through dinner like that right 100 you
ready for the last question I love the
tricky one bro it's an emotional one you
ready yeah what is it worth to you to
have 2 000 hours of footage of
conversations of your father grandfather
grandmother what is the word to you a
lot
think about that
what would you do today you know what I
would be doing today
I'd be sitting there glued to the screen
going through 2 000 hours of content
documenting to see what my grandpa was
thinking in 1924 and 1941 and 1930 this
one that's all you'd be thinking about
what you and I don't know bro is that's
what our kids are going to have one day
grandkids are going to have one day when
we're dead yeah man think about that all
the time that is emotional it's on the
Forefront of my brain all the time that
is so and I remember I loved my
grandfather my especially on my mother's
side and I remember you know really
listening to him I I I really when he
died I remember having no regrets I
remember I said man I spent and I'm
gonna feel the same way about my father
I spent so much time with them and I and
I spend real time with them and you know
because a lot of people don't get that
in life a lot of people don't have a
father or they don't have time they
don't get that chance so and I'm aware
of that and you know that's one of the
things that no matter what I know when
when when my father goes I'll know that
I'll know that I spent and you know all
that quality time but to have that
recorded oh my God are you kidding me no
oh right are you kidding you know every
man they say that most men and women who
are historically significant all of them
kept a diary of some kind all of them
almost all of them wrote something every
day which I didn't know but I read that
recently and but you know podcasting you
know I've been doing this now for I
don't know how many years it's just a
record man it's a record I said a lot of
[__] but you know have you done have
you ever watched have you ever watched a
movie
hear me out the question have you ever
watched the same movie back to back in
four hours
ah yes what movie I mean for me it was
Raging Bull I thought you were going to
say porn but
yes that as well I had to watch that
again I liked some of your work too male
on mail stuff you like that no that was
Adam yeah
okay okay yeah oh Adam Adam what a voice
right I love it
Raging Bull yeah and uh I recently
watched Stutz uh twice but that's a
different thing yeah Vinnie you got one
a movie you watch same movie you know
how you put a song on repeat and it
keeps playing playing Good Fellas I
watched I could do the whole movie good
I've watched over and over and over and
over again have you watched the same
movie two times in four hours same movie
one thousand percent which one Good
Fellas you've watched it I've it's
disgusting I don't know if you've ever
done this before well number one
anything with Vince Vaughn and then
shout out to Brian Callan The Hangover I
could watch that thing bang bang bang
bang
you know what it is for me for me it's
the judge okay it's the only movie I've
watched
really watch the judge the backpack back
on a flight back from Europe I just
watched it and it's done I wondered
about them came back I watched it why
what was it about it oh my God it's the
verdict changed in the second one first
of all Robert Downey Jr to me
you know how you said intuition and you
were talking about women having tuition
I think it's also for me it would be
people who have seen a lot or gone
through a lot of [__] typically have
intuition I just you know I can't use
the word love with actors
but I can say I love this guy man the
way the guy acts and you know when he
went through his mess and he came back
the Redemption I mean he's just such a
so you're watching this movie and I was
telling the uh who we're talking to
today I don't want to name drop you know
our friend uh JP JP yeah Entourage uh uh
we're talking to him and you know what I
said you know when you played Entourage
Ari you were not acting I said I I
believe you were that guy you know
Robert Downey Jr did an act in this
movie it was him it was him and Robert
Duvall was his father I've had JP help
me on acting roles he's the guy is sick
you want to talk about a guy who
understands that guy he because he his
mother was an acting teacher his father
was an acting teacher do you know that
of course yeah
and his sisters also Sheriff yeah she's
also done she's married to Adam McKay
right oh wow big shorts directed you
know talented at night
[Music]
yeah but he's uh yeah that guy
understands acting on a deep no no she's
something else but I'm watching this
movie so there's a there's a scene in
there where the youngest brother is like
an autistic kid you know he's got
something that he's dealing with Downs
not down syndrome but he's dealing with
something and he shows an old clip
because the oldest brother I don't know
if you guys have seen this movie or not
have you seen a movie have you ever seen
this movie bro first of all whatever you
do on the flight back figure out a way
to watch this on your phone I'm telling
you you're going to be blown away by
this one I am not he said is it a new
movie oh no no it's an older movie
if you're you're a movie guy you're
gonna be blown away by it I can't
believe I'm here bro it's such a sick
that is a judge him and his dad have the
biggest falling out he leaves the small
City to go become one of the biggest
lawyers in all of America then his
mother dies he is forced to come back to
his mom's funeral and him and his dad
have the biggest Feud because that The
Three Brothers the two have the same
personality him dad and himself wow and
so much is revealed because the oldest
brother was a pitcher he was about to go
into major leagues there's an accident
his arm gets hurt doesn't go into the
major leagues and the youngest brother
one day they're in the basement he's
playing the old video clips of the
brothers throwing the ball and he's
doing this and he's doing that and then
the youngest brother plays a clip of the
oldest brother's car accident damn the
dad gets upset throws it turn that [__]
off turn that [__] off turn it off I
told you turn it off then he breaks the
camera I mean it's a very very don't
tell me anymore yeah I don't want to
tell you but I'm just telling you but by
the way I will watch this movie over and
over again you know what I like to do
with this movie I like to watch this
movie with people for the first time and
just watch their reaction I love I do
this is that movie I like to watch this
movie with people just to see how you
react to it do you know what young actor
used to look up to Robert Duvall and
mimic him who do you think it was a
young actor are you talking about
yourself well that's for sure but no not
Tom Cruise Robert De Niro really De
Niro's he he Brando and Duvall they used
to watch it was De Niro and
somebody else but they used to watch
Duvall if you ever watch dinero if you
watch watched in there when he laughs
you know he does that yeah that thing oh
that's such a Duvall thing watch Duvall
yeah watch Duvall you're right in his
earlier movies yeah that came from
Duvall wow when you watch the great
Santini and he's drunk and he's going
you know the great have you seen the
great Santini that's that bro he has to
watch that Pat
that's about that's about a father and a
son relationship you got to get that
under your belt the great Santini Robert
Duvall done forget it done and I put the
judge on my face I gotta see this I
can't wait but you know what's crazy too
as an actor and you know I and I'm a
movie buff and he knows this I've never
even heard of The Judge first I swear to
God 2014. so so I so listen I went to
The Breakers and I see Robert Duvall I I
go to him I say hey Robert can I just
tell you something he says what's that I
said in Iran we watched Godfather in
Farsi I said you have to subscribe a c
let me tell you my experience when I
went to Iran he started telling me these
stories ah I'm like we have a picture to
get I'm like you know some people like
how you see celebrities you're like
whatever you interview all these people
I was like dude you're Robert Duvall
holy you're not just standing you're
just your rapper Duvall right when you
see that so but when you watch the judge
I'm like dying to tell you how to move
yes but I'm not gonna do it to you I'm
gonna I'm gonna watch it tonight dude I
had Sylvester Stallone read Rocky he
read the script like I'm standing there
with him and he's reading from the
original screenplay oh my God I'm right
there he's reading when was it where was
this well I also I also am there with
him in his foyer when Sugar Ray Leonard
and I have it on video Sugar Ray Leonard
is showing me how because I say to him I
go champ I'm like I asked you because we
I go not to bother you but we were all
talking and I go when I'm bi when I'm I
when I'm jab when I'm going when I try
to go here and then I go here and I'm
going for the body if I'm gonna hit the
body when I make this transition I keep
getting hit because that was true I just
couldn't I couldn't hunt the body I
realized I could pop up and as you're
turning you get hit right so I go how do
you how do you dig to the body I'm
asking him so he starts teaching me he
starts teaching me
Stallone says to my right there there it
is oh [__] look look look at this look
at this look it's slow
come on come on dude dude you I have no
business asking him this [__] anyway
but seriously who am I yeah who is this
kid seriously what the fighter for the
kid look at me look at him me look at
him teachers so what a moment dude where
are you guys that's in Strong's house
holy yeah that's that's
crazy is that one of his daughters by
the way yeah great girls yeah I bet
dude by the way he couldn't look better
that's that's surreal right there but
Sugar Ray and then and then I had the
same experience with with Pacino in The
Other what the hell is going on dude
whose birthday was it February 3rd we
were just watching I think we were
watching the either we were watching oh
Joshua or the Super Bowl yeah that's the
Super Bowl well I would go to his house
periodically yeah yeah and so it'd be
I'd be there and I'd be like oh and then
Pacino would walk in and David Blaine
then Guy Fieri's in the kitchen making
food and we're all hanging out and I was
like arrived have you seen you know what
this is he won the Oscar when he won the
Oscar and who who creeped up on him
behind him when he won it for Rocky he's
seen that where Ali comes right behind
him
oh that was great yeah moment yeah man
it was it's really those moments are
kind of like at one point I was standing
in a circle with it was I think it was
Schwarzenegger Pacino Stallone and
somebody else and I'm just standing
there listening them talk and Bill Burr
walks by me and where the cigar he goes
you've been here an hour already get
over it
and I was like no I'm not gonna get over
it this is exciting too good by the way
bill is uh uh one of my favorite
favorite uh comedians is Bill Burr we
have my show but I understand no I
appreciate it yeah but you know
it doesn't matter it's not about me
that was so quick I almost missed very
hard for over an hour come to Danny
improv this week so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
[Music]